Pope Francis will wash the feet of 12
inmates at Rome's Central Prison
tomorrow the ritual at the prison dates
back to Francis's first Holy Thursday as
Pope five years ago it led to backlash
from conservatives because women and
Muslims were included it's one of many
actions by Francis that have raised
concerns among conservative Catholics
dozens of theologians priests and
academics accused the Pope of spreading
heresy when his 2016 document called the
joy of love critics panned his opinions
on marriage moral life and the
sacraments New York Times Ross Douthat
believes in the controversy delves
rather into the controversy over that
document and its impact in his new book
to change the church Pope Francis and
the future of Catholicism it's published
by Simon & Schuster a division of CBS
Ross Douthat
welcome thank you for having me you've
been very critical
Pope Francis specifically his decision
to give communion to divorced or we
married couples why because I think it
risks ultimately aspects of Catholicism
that are essential to the church's claim
to be the one true church that connects
itself all the way back to Jesus himself
one of the things that is most
interesting in certain ways about
Catholicism is the way that for all of
its worldly pumps and you know all of
its Pope's getting in wars and you know
and being worldly and causing trouble
it's also the place where you find some
of the strongest words of Jesus still
lived out so Jesus says you know you
must eat my body and drink my blood and
the Catholic Church still says in
communion that's exactly what you do and
in the same way the church is the last
institution really in the Western world
that makes any kind of claim that
Christian marriage is indissoluble I
punish people who give divorce I mean
specifically I punish them and not allow
them to have communion because the
church thinks that you aren't well first
of all you aren't punished by not being
allowed to take communion if you're
divorced no no they counted the church
the church doesn't exclude all right the
church doesn't exclude people who are
divorced from communion it excludes
people who are remarried
without having an annulment of their
first marriage and look these are I mean
my parents and grandparents are both
divorced like most people in our society
I live in a you know a world where
families are broken family structures
are complicated and so on and I wouldn't
want to live in the world where the
church was you know running marriage
tribunals for everyone and sort of
imposing its rules in civil law but what
the church says now is in this culture
where divorce is common and remarriage
is rampant we're going to say that you
know that second marriages if you can't
give an annulment and by the way before
Francis came along annulment rules were
already especially in the u.s. fairly
merciful so what you have under Francis
is just a step towards a kind of you
know the church's teaching is becomes
potentially and look this hasn't fully
talk more about Pope Francis generally
because we should say you became a
Catholic when you were a teenager and
you're very happy about that decision
but you talk about the Pope you say he's
the most powerful person in the church
but what are his powers really right and
this is he bringing people back you call
him a media phenomenon media phenomenon
but is he bringing laps people back into
the church right and in addition to
being a Catholic I'm a journalist you
know as punishment for my sins I guess
and the reality is even if you think
that I'm you know too harsh and
unforgiving on the question of divorce
and remarriage I think the underlying
story here that I try and tell in the
book is just a fascinating one because
the church is right he's the most
powerful man in the church he's an
absolute monarch in certain ways and yet
his powers are supposed to be tightly
circumscribed because he's not supposed
to change essential things that his
predecessors have taught going all the
way back 2,000 years so a lot of the
drama of the Francis pontificate that
you guys alluded to at the start bishops
and theologians arguing with each other
Cardinals challenging the Pope and so on
reflects what happens this fascinating
thing when a Pope sets out to sort of
push the limits of his office and say
you say Rome under Francis is much like
Washington under Trump a paranoid jumpy
praised place there they're both
populist sin effect in effect yeah and I
want to be clear I'm not you know I'm
not drawing any kind of moral comparison
between the Holy Father and President
Trump the campaign
Arsen is more of their their role within
their respective institutions both of
them have entered institutions the US
government and the Church of Rome that
have major credibility problems that are
sort of creaking and straining under the
pressures of modernity and their boat
that they both have sort of factions
that see them as you know making America
great again making Catholicism great
again if you will yeah and a lot of the
tensions a lot of the institutional
tensions are similar even as again there
are very different figures personally
but they both I think speak to this
moment in the West generally where
there's this sense that all of our
institutions governmental religious and
so on aren't working particularly well
and so there are openings for populace
for reformers the question is just
whether those reforms actually deliver
what bail what they're trying to promise
you've raised a lot of interesting
questions in the book thank you very
much to Ross thank you thank you so much
for having me to change the churches on
sale now wherever you like to buy your
books